al concluir el primer día de audiencias
en el juicio de extradición contra el
fundador de wikileaks julian assange no
hubo avances debido a dificultades
técnicas que se presentaron dentro del
tribunal penal o bailey la magistrada a
vanessa bannister no podía escuchar la
comparecencia del testigo de eeuu que se
encontraba a través de una
videoconferencia por lo que el día de
mañana tendrá que reanudar esta
comparecencia
los testigos provenientes de eeuu al
concluir el primer día el padre de
julian assange john shipton señaló que
las dificultades técnicas impidieron
estos avances al principio de la
audiencia se presentó julian assange
donde confirmó su nombre y también dijo
categóricamente que no consentía ser
extraditado a los estados unidos
mientras tanto afuera desde temprana
hora
dio cita a un grupo de simpatizantes
además de organizaciones no
gubernamentales como amnistía
internacional y reporteros sin fronteras
que exigen la liberación de julian
assange y también están pidiendo que no
sea extraditado a los estados unidos
este juicio durará al menos cuatro
semanas sin embargo podría haber
apelaciones y en total podría llegar
hasta dos años y sería la corte suprema
la que tuviera la palabra final